in these chests is over 100 000 worth of
gift cards and all of these minecraft
creators are going to be racing to see
who can find the 100 000 worth of gift
cards first
[Music]
i have invisibility arrows so that might
be an advantageous strategy
i actually have frankly i don't see how
we could lose i'm just i'm so hyped
we're gonna do so well i can see it
i want to start the scavenger hunt with
the bang so i tweeted the first
challenge
guys check jimmy's twitter chick jimmy's
twitter oh gonna go check jimmy's
twitter
what did the beast tweet kill someone on
the dream smp for your first hit kill
someone
okay no this is bad i don't know how to
kill anybody
you have to kill someone for your first
time sorry nietzsche
just killed me and took all my stuff
separate just killed me where are the
people at where the people at where the
people at where's jm
oh now no one can see him i'm sorry
nikki no purple please
kill each other
oh my god they're just killing nikki
where are people
where's cole don't call cole
fundy's killing me phil kill me phil
kill me phil kill me and share the
hidden okay he'll kill me
there's no way i'm killing anybody else
so i mean all right carl where's my head
connor killed himself i guess that
counts and speaking of big prizes we're
giving away ten
thousand dollars to one of our
subscribers so if you want a chance to
win hit that subscribe button
right now i'm sending it to you on
twitter the the new clue okay perfect
thank you
it's pretty simple if one of the players
got a kill i had carl send that player a
picture
guys the hint was that it's in a desert
okay so he's standing on
a diamond block with two signs what's on
top of the fence
where is the desert guys it's in the
desert and there's a lead and a diamond
block
okay so where's the nearest desert carl
hasn't messaged me
where's my clue called we can figure out
the direction
if we can figure out where the sun is
hello do you work with mr beast
yes i do sorry
hello hello why are you all alone
everyone else is with each other i
am against teaming mr beast just for
that i'll give you an extra hit it's a
large desert jack i honestly might go
have a nap don't have a nap pong
you're not thinking straight hello jimmy
how are you i'm good
okay all right the hundred thousand
dollars in gift cards is comprised of a
ten thousand dollar best buy ten
thousand dollar game stop ten thousand
dollar hearties ten thousand dollar taco
bell
basically everything you ever wanna buy
until you die
is here let's say theoretically i want
to buy a lionfish what gift card would
help me with that one
oh oh perfect so there's actually five
thousand dollar bass pro shop gift card
we need to go we need to
go before i go just think of my favorite
numbers 69 420 69 420 all right there we
go we can fast travel
wilbur no use the checkpoints you fall
i'm going on a hunch and i'm just gonna
go to minus six nine six nine
and then plus six nine six nine there
wasn't really anything
uh minus six thousand nine hundred or
six nine six nine wait hold up there's a
chest on some leaves
it says lol
someone just said try the year his
channel was made and my first thought
was no no one's that obsessed with
youtube
and then i went oh wait yeah let's look
at this channel
x-ray texture pack that'd be a great
idea however i feel like that would be
considered cheating
am i above that no i think what we
should do is uh get the chance to do it
for us so go on the seed everyone i've
shown the strength
i'm just running looking for desert
eventually so many chunks are being
loaded at the same time that the map
literally couldn't keep up with the lag
wait fellas is the server really laggy
what happened to this server the chunks
aren't loading how's anyone meant to get
anywhere if we just keep glitching back
stop let me craft i need to craft
we need help oh my gosh
that was not an unloaded challenge that
was an actual chunk that someone dug out
yes i
literally almost died so dream had to
reset the server
closed no no the sub just died no
after the server reset we realized that
people were getting much closer to the
gift cards
oh no i actually think those coordinates
i put in chat may be it because there's
a desert there
oh go go go go go then go what the
muffin where is the desert
i got a disc where you got a disc i got
this is that part of the clue that's
part of the clue i'll send you the clue
right now
i'm sending it to you okay i'm saying
i'm showing you
your green screen gets green screen no
way as time passed by basically the
entire dream smp showed up
even corpse hopped on the server what's
up tv oh what's up corks
hey corpse cops how are you i'm upset
that's a drake song you know you're not
gonna win
what if i told you i was paid to lower
your morale
although there's legitimately one this
is 69 420. it's 69 420
t he i've went this far just to be
completely screwed with haven't i i've
been
screwed with george i just realized
something about you yeah you know the
chords just as much as you know about
colors
i might end the stream actually guys
whoa oh
i want a hen i want a hint right now my
stream is just me staring at the ocean
eating pistachio
okay so we know it's not 69 420 that's
in the middle of the ocean but it could
be
4 26 96 9. what do you think my next
hint should be maybe we could just
narrow it down and say it's and say it's
a positive positive
things were taking a little longer than
i thought they would so i tweeted out a
huge hint to speed it up guys check
jimmy's newest reply to tommy hurry guys
hurry guys
tommy mr beast just replied to you hey
tommy don't tell
anyone else but the chords are all
positive okay we gotta go to the other
side mr beast why would you tweet that
mr beast now everyone else could see he
waited for us to be negative corners and
then tweeted out
to go the other way or draw positive oh
good that's good i've been going
positive the whole time
maybe he was lying to tommy he did say
that that hint was only for tommy
remember
that's the thing i can't tell if that's
like an actual hint or he's meaning
carl just woke me up give me a heart
attack all the chords are positive my
friend
give me 15 more minutes and i'll come
back online okay and at this point i
really needed to hop into everyone's
calls and just see how they were doing
mr beast do you like pistachios oh i
love them you two are getting along
aren't you
i have an entire bag for you here mr
beast if you want to fly on over to
brighton you know just for that i'm
gonna dm you something
oh god please after the stream mr beast
please
now that i have a general idea of where
it could be i'm just kind of walking and
praying i'm gonna go in the positive
diagonal direction oh but i can't really
go there it's in the desert oh really
thanks chat when when are we allowed to
give up
guys i've had enough desert please nope
looks like snow
there's no hope dude see this map here
this is where everyone currently is
and this is where the gift cards
actually are phillip you at six nine six
nine yeah i'm gonna beat the one that
you posted pretty soon
okay go phil you got this go oh wait
i've been going to that in the nether
please put your mess in the chat from
now on i've gone i'm at 4k in the nether
there's a tweet there's a tweet that's a
tweet
after an hour and honestly what i
thought would be enough him i followed
up with a new
even bigger hint on twitter it's as easy
as
e it's easy as a b c d e what would
a b c d e mean one two three four five a
b
c easy as death what's the glucose
the clue is it's in the desert
why well we can try one two three four
five one two three four five actually
because
we're not far away from that okay here
we go boom baby i'm gonna try one two
three four five i'm gonna try it
and tommy is literally here kill him
kill him
oh bbh is here corner's got to be
positive so we've got our head this way
what did mr b say give me what mr b said
it's as easy as abchida it's one two
three uh easy as one two three
there's no way it's in that one desert
that we were at because that desert was
not in positive coordinates
maybe it's 420 one two three people that
tell me one two three four five
on the x and the z axis is a desert oh
that is so far that's 12k 12k
wait 12k 12k in the overworld right in
overworld blocks i'm traveling at
immense speeds right now because i have
a horse with speed going through the
nether which is eight times faster than
the overworld guys
check jimmy's twitter chick jimmy's
twitter check jimmy's twitter i'm
checking i'm checking i'm checking
checking
there's nothing no i just want to make
sure you guys have notifications on
there's multiple people here there's
rambu and jack manifold
could be there but also couldn't jimmy
if i give you
like three quid will you give us a clue
just for that i'm leaving
oh sorry sorry it wasn't enough money
that's a desert oh that's a desert it's
so crazy because like any second now it
just pop in and render and then boom
that's fifty thousand dollars
obviously one two three four five right
it was just a funny number some
combination
of 69 420 and one two three four five i
reckon the end number's just 420. so the
coordinates didn't have 69 or 420 at all
so i dropped
the final hint mr beast tweeted the last
hint let me see
one of the coordinates is zero one of
the coordinates is zero
don't pick the wrong one hey what if the
y is zero could it be y
zero wait is it zero one two three four
five fine oh brilliant i'm already going
now i'm not even far away i'm not even
far away enough to bother with the
nether i don't think
wait we're really near there already
phil no i found
no no no no no we found it we found it
we found it oh
oh oh i found it what really
wait no jack manifold's gonna kill me
we've always found a hundred thousand
it's underground within a hundred block
radius get digging oh wait jack mata
is going significantly faster than i am
where have you gone where have you gone
kill him get digging
100 radius okay come on baby
never give up i'm literally just jump
running i'm not gonna skid out or i'm
winning we're all gonna come and kill
you jack manifold
i will win yeah i see the diamond i see
the diamond oh my god where's my portal
i lost
it phil i see you
missed it i'm stressing out have you
found it tobo
yes i got it
congratulations on literally winning a
hundred thousand dollars
thank you oh my god how does one give
away this much money
do whatever the heck you want just start
opening books if you wanted the top
chest is for you
and the other chest you open up on
stream next page
open at your own race oh god it actually
is a code this is crazy